une réunion spéciale de l'organisation
de l'aviation civile internationale va
se tenir mardi à montréal pour discuter
du danger de survoler des zones de
conflit l'organisation a convoqué cette
réunion réponse à l'explosion de l'avion
de la malaysia airlines en ukraine sur
le terrain le rapatriement des corps se
poursuivent sur fond de crise politique
à kiev frédéric nicoloff
en annonçant sa démission le premier
ministre ukrainien a créé la surprise
une démission toutefois que le parlement
du pays devra entériner et qui
intervient dans le sillage de la
dissolution de la coalition
gouvernementale si
une décision que regrette une bonne
partie de la population ukrainienne
il a travaillé pour le bien du pays dix
résidents au kiev j'aurais voulu qu'il
reste à son poste car je pense que c'est
le seul qui peut mener le pays vers la
prospérité
tout semble indiquer que le pays se
dirige vers des élections législatives
cet automne ce qui permettra au nouveau
président d'imposer son autorité sur un
parlement qui lui étaient réfractaires
jusqu'à présent
pendant sept ans à kharkiv dans l'est du
pays les cercueils qui contiennent les
corps des victimes de l'écrasement du
vol de la malaisie a airlines continue
d'être chargé dans des avions cargos à
destination des pays bas
là comme plus tôt cette semaine sous
bonne escorte ils sont acheminés dans
des convois funéraires vers une base
militaire où les corps seront identifiés
les pays bas exige maintenant que les
coupables soient jugés chez eux riche en
options il y a plusieurs options comme
la cour de justice internationale dit le
premier ministre mais avant cela il faut
trouver les coupables et les preuves de
leur syndrome une semaine jour pour jour
après la tragédie le dernier vol portant
le numéro m h 17 de la malaysia airlines
a atterri à l'aéroport de kuala lumpur
la capitale ce sera la deuxième fois que
la compagnie retire ainsi un numéro de
vol
frédéric au colloque radio canada
montréal